now next this afternoon boris johnson
has pulled out of a major conference
looking at the issues around leveling up
in northern england he had been expected
to address a meeting held by
conservative mps cabinet members local
councillors and also business leaders in
doncaster but our deputy political
editor sam coats is in doncaster for us
this afternoon waiting patiently uh any
reason do we know some why boris
johnson's not going to be there
we don't know yet we're expecting an
announcement from downing street in the
next hour or so we are assured that it's
a good reason for him pulling out uh
that uh of what could have been quite a
sticky conference here at the northern
research group's annual first annual
conference here at doncaster racecourse
the conference is going on
next to me hundreds of conservative mps
from the north activists business people
all gathered here to put pressure on the
party to try and give a greater focus uh
to the people of the north try and win
uh once again some of those red wool
seats potentially even uh to win uh some
new ones uh now that's been the job
today but boris johnson uh is a no show
the organizers were only told in the
last couple of hours uh they are
mystified they don't know the reason yet
uh but they are they are assured that is
of significant
sufficient significance that nobody will
ask any questions about whether or not
this event was just too sticky uh for
the prime minister uh to attend so it's
continuing to go on and i'm joined by a
couple of people that have turned up uh
chris green is the mp for bolton west
and katie burgess is a former mayoral
candidate for liverpool not known uh for
being a traditional conservative
heartland casey start with you
boris johnson has particular
significance in liverpool not
necessarily in a good way how is he
going down now and what does he need to
do to reassure
the voters in your area
i think in liverpool boris will always
be boris i don't think his reputation
will improve or deteriorate regardless
of what he does i think generally people
want to see him deliver on promises they
want to see this government improve the
area like they promised they did and
regardless of who they're voting for
locally they want westminster to keep
those promises to hold those people to
account and to deliver what we're
wanting do you think boris johnson is
the best person to lead the conservative
party as far as people in your area is
concerned uh probably not for merseyside
um he came with a reputation um that
said i think there are people who have
warned to him there are certainly
younger voters who like boris he offers
something that they maybe haven't seen
before or that they don't see in
politics
certain things that have gone on we've
had covert we've had things but it's i
think ultimately um he's not doing any
damage to the area i think if anything
else um chris green this is an event
where
frankly boris jones was probably going
to come here face northern mps thoughts
face some of those figures he didn't
vote for him in that vote of no
confidence uh in order to as it were uh
renew his marriage vows to the people
here
how do you think his no-show will go
down and just before you answer that did
you vote for him in the vote of my
confidence uh well it's a it's a private
vote so i'm not going to comment
publicly because i think it's unfair and
colleagues uh because the media is going
to play that game or kind of narrow down
who's on which side and that
factionalism i don't think that's very
useful it would have been great if the
prime minister had been able to make it
and i don't know why he's been uh called
away but i don't think it's a fear uh
factor i think this is a really positive
conference the northern research group
is setting out a pretty good agenda for
the north of england boris johnson is
enthusiastic about that so i think this
would have should have been a great
event for him and i don't think he's too
worried about the reception because i
know it would be very good you've just
heard some of the criticism of
people in the area about boris johnson
do you think that boris johnson is still
a vote winner in places like this uh
yeah i'm from liverpool as well so
all politicians of any background have
a mixed feeling uh locally wherever it
might be uh but i think boris johnson
has huge skills and yeah we we
appreciate the vote uh recently uh
amongst uh conservative members of
parliament that boris johnson is best
when he's under pressure he's under a
bit of pressure now and this is where he
i think he's going to come out and start
delivering
what do you think the people in the room
in there the voters in this area need to
hear from the conservatives what is the
policy suggestion or the direction of
travel that you think is missing needs
to be re-injected into the debate
i think with our leveling up agenda we
need to see that leveling up of
opportunity and i think it's about
gaining consensus for what people need
and want and it's a fine balance so we
don't help people when we do it for them
but if we can create an opportunity that
leads to people then taking those
opportunities and building for
themselves it's about independence um
chris i sometimes listen to debates
particularly amongst northern
conservatives about what direction you
should take leveling up and all i hear
is spending spending spending spending
on subsidies spending on investment
is that very conservative does that ever
concern you
it does concern me and not always very
conservative and i was quite pleased to
be on the the panel about net zero which
is quite an expensive area if you get
into the detail now i think there ought
to be a huge agenda on cutting the cost
of energy prices getting the reshoring
the return on manufacturing uh to
britain but also i think that will
disproportionately come to the north of
england so this is what i want to see
and i think the the positive agenda the
government's got is hinckley c seiswell
uh is going to have a nuclear power
station the small modular reactor agenda
this isn't about subsidies fundamentally
this is about making sure the united
kingdom has affordable energy to make
sure we can power our industry
you hear a lot of different things
including from cabinet ministers about
what even this government's economic
policy is some want to cut taxes some
want to reduce debt some want to target
inflation uh some want to deregulate
somewhat to help people out by uh making
the banks lend to riskier people does
this government even have an economic
policy i think there needs to be a more
clarity on this and one of the
challenges has been during covet uh we
had to act in a way which was a bit out
of kilter with traditional conservative
approaches we had to intervene more and
the repercussions of kovit and the
lockdown as well whether it's an
education whether it's in business
whether it's in the wider healthcare
means we have to intervene more than we
would like but we have to get through
the other side of this thank you very
much both indeed uh you had a point of
view maybe boris johnson not best for
the merseyside region at least and also
a conservative mp not quite sure that he
can say wholeheartedly this government
has an economic policy lots of
challenges that boris johnson wasn't
able to address today all right so many
thanks indeed sam coach sarah doncaster